administrators at Riverview high school
surveyed a random sample of 100 of their
seniors to see how they felt about the
lunch offerings at the school's
cafeteria so you have all of the seniors
I'm assuming there's more than a hundred
of them and then they sampled a hundred
of them so this is the sample so the
population is all of the seniors at the
school that's the population all of the
seniors and they sampled a hundred of
them
so the hundred seniors that they talked
to that is the sample that is the sample
so they tell us identify the population
in the sample in the setting so let's
just see which of these choices actually
match up to what I just said it like
always I encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can work through it
on your own so the population is all
high school seniors in the world the
sample is all of the seniors at
Riverview high no this is not right
we're not trying to figure out we're not
trying to get an indication of how all
of the high school seniors in the world
feel about the food at Riverview high
school we're trying to get an indication
of how the seniors at Riverview high
school feel about the the lunch at the
school's cafeteria so they did a sample
of hundred of them so this is definitely
not going to be let me cross this one
out the population is all students at
Riverview high the sample is all of the
seniors at Riverview high well they
didn't they clearly didn't sample all of
the seniors they sample a hundred of the
seniors so this isn't going to be right
either let's hope that the third choice
is working out the population is all
seniors at Riverview high the sample is
the hundred seniors survey yep that's
exactly what we talked here we're trying
to get an indication about how all of
the seniors at Riverview high feel about
the food the lunch offerings we probably
think it's impractical or the
administrators feel it's impractical to
talk to everyone so to get exactly what
the population thinks so instead they're
going to a random sample of a hundred of
them so the sample is the hundred
seniors who are actually surveyed